The five key data standards are,
the International Classification
of Diseases, ICD.
Current Procedural Terminology, CPT.
Logical Observation Identifiers Names
and Codes, LOINC.
National Drug Code NDC.
And Systematized Nomenclature for
Medicine, or SNOMED.
ICD and CPT are very widely used because
they're required in most cases for
medical billing.
CPT and NDC are pretty much US specific.
ICD, LOINC, and SNOMED
are internationally used ontologies,
capable of representing clinical
relationships among their elements.
NDC and CPT are classifications,
although CPT increasingly
has sub-codes to provide more details
about a procedure for use in billing.